so anyway so Dennis said I couldn't give
my Turing Award talk so you're gonna get
a different talk and what this is is my
view of what Big Data means means to me
and I'll talk to it in the context of
disruption because if there's no
disruption then the then the big
elephants will just continue to do their
thing not nothing much is going to
change so most of this will be about
what's likely to disrupt the big data
market and then the other context is the
800-pound gorilla in the corner which is
where is their big pain which again
means you know disruption and
opportunity so what is Big Data mean
well I take a very simplistic view it's
the three V's and you don't have to take
pictures of the slides you guys have the
slides so it so it means the three V's
you've either got a big data problem
because you got too much of it you got a
volume problem or it's coming at you too
fast and you have a velocity problem or
it's coming at you from too many places
and you have a variety problem so in
terms of big volume there's sort of two
subcategories that I want to talk about
one is if all you want to do is sequel
analytics count some max min average
group I predicates that stuff the other
thing you might want to do is more
complex analytics that goes under the
rubric data science I'll talk about both
of those so they're really before topics
so let's start with you're happy with
doing sequel analytics and you want to
do it on petabytes of data well this is
in my opinion a solve problem it's
solved in that I know of about 20 or so
production databases that are Terra that
are petascale on large clusters that are
in production doing sequel analytics on
huge amounts of data so for example
Vertica is one of the warehouse vendors
the space their largest customer is a
company called Zynga which is here in
San Francisco does the game farmville
and a bunch of other games and every
time you click on anything in any Zynga
game a record gets entered into a data
warehouse somewhere or other it's got
about five petabytes of data right now
and is being used day-in day-out for
production analytics so there's lots of
examples of this stuff in practice on
petabytes of data on very large clusters
think 500 and up nodes and by and large
these customers are not unhappy with
their database systems you know they're
they're struggling with operational
problems like what how do you how do you
replace nodes on you know a big cluster
without going down and all that kind of
stuff
so operations are difficult but not the
data manager so I consider this solved
so if you think there's going to be any
disruption you know the big vendors are
pretty good at this stuff so the one
thing you do need to know is that of the
various vendors who are all ostensibly
offering column stores which is the
right technology to offer with
compression on all the columns
performance among the various offerings
differs by a lot think one to two orders
of magnitude so if you're actually going
to buy one of these puppies it's
important to figure out whether it's
going to work well on your workload and
test more than one product the other
thing is some vendors are on version 1
or version 2 others are on version 8
that correlates perfectly with how many
bugs you can expect to see so maturity
and and reliability is going to differ
by a lot Oracle which is a big player in
the database space does not have a
column store and does not run shared
nothing
multiple nodes even though their
marketing claims to the contrary so my
favorite joke about Oracle is you want
to know what hardware platform Oracle
runs the best on anyone want to take a
guess a 35-millimeter slide projector or
its modern-day equivalent powerpoint
some products are native column stores
meaning they were written originally as
a column store some products used to be
row stores until they realized that
column stores were an order of magnitude
or more faster and so they have
converted from count from rows doors to
column stores in some cases that
conversion is not yet done
so beware of anybody who used to be a
row store and some products have a
serious marketing problem meaning
they're invisible other products have a
serious marketing problem which is they
lie to you and claim that they do
something that they don't actually do so
all the commercial products customer
beware but now let's turn to what's
going to change in this market so here
are some possible disruptions first one
is NVRAM is right around the corner
Facebook is a big enthusiast of running
stuff on NVRAM not non-volatile memory
so non-volatile memory is faster than
flash and not much more expensive so it
will it will allow you to say my storage
hierarchy is l2 cache then main memory
then nvram then flash then disk now no
serious systems person is going to
suggest trying to manage a five level
hierarchy so some number of these levels
are going to be interesting some but not
all of them
your mileage will vary anyway nvram is
going to be an element of the storage
hierarchy and is not going to be
particularly disruptive to the current
vendors the thing that might be somewhat
disruptive is that 40-gig II is coming
and all of these products have been
engineered to try very hard not to send
not to use network bandwidth so they've
all assumed that networking is a high
pole in the tent there's a reasonable
probability that's no longer going to be
true if so it gives you more flexibility
but the main vendors in this space
realize this and are and are going to be
adapting the thing that's a little more
problematic is that all the money in
this market is at the high end so if you
want to run Vertica is one of the better
systems in this space and you have a
terabyte or less on three nodes or less
it's free so the the low end has been
completely commoditized and cost nothing
so all the money's at the high end so
all of this is going to be modest
disruption at best the other thing to
always keep in mind is that the size of
data warehouses is getting bigger faster
than resources are getting cheaper so
this space is not getting any easier
it's going to remain hard at the high
end which means people are going to
continue to pay big bucks for these kind
of systems at the high end so these are
not going to be serious storm clouds but
there is a serious storm cloud which is
these guys are all solving yesterday's
problem and everyone will be happy to
admit that as soon as Stanford and
everybody else can train enough data
scientists the data science is going to
replace business intelligence as the
operational load against big warehouses
so data scientists are not going to be
retreaded business analysts bi folks are
just smart enough to run business you
know the business intelligence tools
that produce sequel queries on their
behalf will never get through the talk
if we if we take questions now okay so
why is data science such a good idea
well business intelligence will give you
a big table of numbers which you can
look at with tableau or whatever you
want to look at or you can have a
predictive model that will allow you to
generate some assumptions and it like
what is going to happen so would you
rather have a predictive model or a big
table of numbers everybody in their
right mind will take the predictive
model so this is going to happen it may
take a decade for us to train enough
data scientists to actually be able to
do this stuff but it's certainly going
to come now what is that what does data
science mean to me well what is it what
is the data scientists actually do so he
first of all tries to figure out what
dataset he wants to run analytics on
that's data management and then he does
his favorite complex analytics so he
does clustering he does predictive
modeling he does regression dot dot dot
dot dot dot dot so the data management
is sequel like stuff however the complex
analytics is mostly array based
calculations it's linear algebra to
convince you of that I want to do a very
simple example so this is something
that's real accessible and so if you
look on Wall Street and you look at the
guys who do electronic trading they're
looking for patterns in the CNBC
firehose that goes by you you know
across the bottom of your screen they've
got 20 years worth of data in as much
detail as you want so let's just look at
the closing price on all trading days
back 20 years
for two stocks a and B so if you think a
and B are correlated you'd like to
compute the covariance of those two time
series and if they're positively
correlated if one goes up you buy the
other if they're negatively correlated
if one goes up you short the other and
so forth so that's kind of what
electronic traders want to do so the red
stuff at the bottom of the slide is the
covariance that I copied out of a linear
algebra book and it's correct no one has
disputed that it does what it says it
does so that's not very difficult you
can certainly do this calculation on
your iPhone so to make it interesting
there are about 15,000 publicly traded
stocks in the US there's 60,000
worldwide if you look at the options
market it goes much bigger let's just
use 15,000 US stocks and we have 20,000
we have we have two we have twenty years
worth of data which is approximately
4000 trading days so what what I want to
do is do in all pairs covariance for all
15,000 stocks compute the covariance for
all pairs of those stocks okay so the
red stuff is this a row for each stock
which is the 20-year history of its
closing price which is about 4,000 cells
long so I want to do in all pairs
covariance and so what's the answer
well ignoring the constants and
forgetting about subtracting off the
mean that computation is that red matrix
stock times its transpose times meaning
matrix multiply and so I could have put
up you know singular value decomposition
all the other stuff people do it all
breaks down into this sort of stuff so a
lot of it is on top of matrix multiply
or matrix multiply and matrix matrix
transpose so if you want to do complex
analytics it's this kind of stuff it's
linear algebra it's array based
calculations it is not table based this
is not a table calculation
so how do you support a data scientist
who wants to do data management and he
wants to do complex analytics like
matrix multiply
so rewind about a decade and the first
option which was proselytized buys
Google was to say well just use
MapReduce so MapReduce you know was a
map operation reduce operation and
Hadoop was the open source version of
MapReduce MapReduce was on top of the
Google file system HDFS is the open
source version of that so coded in
MapReduce for HDFS so the thinking at
the time was Google is a bunch of smart
people this is what they think is a good
idea
so we'll just drink the Google kool-aid
and do the same thing so this was option
one drink the Google kool-aid
code your data science stuff in
MapReduce so way back when this was
considered the best thing since sliced
bread however what happened subsequently
was Google quietly abandoned MapReduce
for the application for which it was
purpose-built
which is to run their crawl database so
they abandon they move their crawl
database on the big table and sort of
quietly built other data management
solutions like Dremel and f1 and
bigquery and pretty much at Google
MapReduce went into a long sunset swoon
and in 2015 Google officially abandoned
MapReduce as having no place in their
stack for internal or external use so
here we said something goes from being
the best thing since sliced bread to
being officially abandoned in less than
a decade well that didn't stop cloud era
so in about 2012 or 2013 it became clear
that MapReduce is actually primarily a
sequel market meaning if you asked
Facebook what fraction of your load is
in hive and what fraction of it is in
MapReduce 95 96 97 percent of it was in
hive so and that Facebook is a huge
proponent of MapReduce or at least it
was at the time so it's clear that that
high hive is the answer and that
MapReduce is really a sequel market and
people who code in MapReduce if there's
a few of them but it's kind of some
little Eddy off over there someplace so
if you're cloud era and you're peddling
MapReduce you've got a big problem
because MapReduce is not where it's at
so cloud era did a great bait and switch
they redefined the Hadoop market to not
be MapReduce anymore it's now a three
level stack sequel at the top
ie hive MapReduce in the middle HDFS at
the bottom that lasted only a little
while until 2014 when cloud era released
a system called Impala Impala is a
sequel engine because the problem with
hive is it's ridiculously slow and so
clearly you're going to need something
better if you wanted to actually have
this have some legs so Impala was
released and it's a sequel engine at the
top MapReduce is nowhere to be found and
it talks to a file system underneath it
so it's two-level stack so cloud era
redefines it to be a three level stack
then throws out the middle tier and this
is sequel on top of HDFS and Mike Olson
who's the chairman of the board of cloud
era is happy well not very happy but if
you give him a beer and talk to him
privately he's happy to admit that no
but he is interested in MapReduce
anymore the other thing that's a dirty
little secret is that Impala is not even
based on HDFS they drill directly
through HDFS to the underlying local
Linux file system
so really Impala is sequel at the top
and Linux files at the bottom which is
exactly how all the data warehouse
products also work so why do they don't
like not like HDFS well nobody wants a
very slow location transparent
filesystem it gives database folks a big
case of indigestion in effect what we're
down to is a one level stack sequel so
what that means is that the data
warehouse market which is sequel and the
Hadoop market are merging and so I think
that's fine may the best parallel sequel
column store win so one view of the
Hadoop market is that it's now a sequel
market and it's now the data where part
of the data warehouse market if you want
to deploy a data warehouse on top of
HDFS that's fine the all the vendors
will do it they're all going to drill
through HDFS and talk directly to
underlying Linux files so what's left
for HDFS if this is a sequel market well
again there's been a great pivot the
marketing guys have gone to work and now
HDFS is being marketed to support
something called data Lakes so that's
the new buzzword for what the Hadoop
market is it's about data Lakes
first of all HDFS is a file system it's
hard to imagine getting big bucks for a
file system that's that's a commodity
thing that should just be around so so
it's not clear how you're gonna get a
lot of money by peddling HDFS and as a
data Lake it's certainly possible to use
HDFS for a data Lake but stay tuned be
because we're gonna talk about the big
variety problem in just a little bit and
my contention is that if you just use
HDFS you solve a very small parched
portion of the variety problem and you
will get a data swamp instead of a data
Lake mainly that's to be to come in a
few slides so now let's go to so
everybody realizes that Hadoop is not
the answer so fast forward to last year
and so I what do you say well if you
want to do complex analytics HDFS is too
slow and MapReduce is not flexible
enough so enter from stage right Matassa
haria and spark so let's move to a main
memory parallel execution environment
code your analytics and spark the new
best thing since sliced bread circa 2015
IBM and others are drinking the smart
kool-aid and to me SPARC gives me a big
case of indigestion so why is that well
first of all spark has no persistence
which is you know it's a main memory
system when you when you turn the power
off the data goes away so where are you
going to store the data in between SPARC
executions you need some some companion
storage system so it's not it's not a
database system it's simply a main
memory framework the second thing
problem with SPARC is so you have this
terrible Terra stores or pedda store
underneath it somewhere and you now do
some data management you extract a
terabyte and you load it into SPARC
so John loads his terabyte into SPARC
let's just say I I used the exact same
terabyte and I loaded into SPARC we now
have two one terabyte copies in main
memory there is no sharing in SPARC no
concept of a shared buffer pool
no sharing whatsoever No
persistence no sharing the other thing
matei figured out which is exactly what
Mike Olsen figured out a few years
earlier is that users want sequel so
when you tie when you just add up how
many spark accesses there are to their
machine learning stuff to their stream
stuffed their sequel stuff all their
different interfaces 70% of it is spark
sequel the main spark market is sequel
which shouldn't surprise anybody that
was the main a dupe market - so now you
have the main market is spark and
database folks look at spark sequel and
say huh there's no indexes in spark
sequel there's so there's no persistence
no sharing no indexes this stuff doesn't
run very fast so the other thing that
that spark does is that if you have
terabytes of data and you have something
you want to do with it the standard
wisdom in all of computer science is you
want to move the small thing - the big
thing and what spark is doing is the
opposite they're taking a terabyte of
data and moving it to main memory where
what you really want to do is take the
small thing this analytic computation
and move it to the data which is inside
the storage engine so you're doing the
wrong thing which is and every database
person on the planet will grimace so
this all gives database folks a serious
case of heartburn well spark is being
used largely for you know prototyping
and it's scale all of these problems are
going to be serious issues so what's the
future a spark well stay tuned we have
more to say so let's look at the third
option for supporting data science which
is why don't we figure out how to move
the query to the data not the opposite
way around
so let's suppose you use your favorite
relational database system for
persistence there's a whole bunch of
warehouse ones that are pretty good at
doing this and they support all support
sharing and they all support very high
performance sequel or most of them do so
what are you going to do for the
analytics if you want to move it inside
the DBMS well some guy named Mike
Stonebraker said let's have user defined
functions and Postgres and that was 20
years ago so there is a user defined
function interface so why don't you just
you can write your user-defined
functions and spark if you want or an R
that's very popular for analytic
computations or in C++ or whatever you
want the only problem with this story so
far is that the support for user-defined
function it's gonna have to improve a
lot
most of the systems don't support
parallel UDF's and these are
computations that run for quite a while
so you want to make them recoverable and
that stuff doesn't work so it's a bunch
of work the database vendors have to do
but in in theory there's nothing that
prevents them from running analytics as
user defined functions written in
whatever language you want to write them
in now the last thing to notice though
is that these are array calculations you
call a UDF and you have a table system
you're gonna have to cast a table to an
array and on all but the largest
problems that conversion is going to be
the high pole in the tent so that's
going to be a major problem with with
format conversion you know in the large
so that brings up the fourth option
which is why don't we get rid of table
database systems in this market and move
to an array database system so that says
that instead of having to convert to
something else to run your analytics
everything is native arrays if you have
sequel on arrays or a sequel like thing
you have my analytics on arrays that's
all runs on the same storage model
and that gives you same database in
database analytics write them in our
write them in spark don't care and that
gives you no table to array conversion
and the we don't want to we never want
to move the data to the query you always
want to do the opposite that's exactly
what the previous solution and this
solution both did this is likely to be
the most efficient long term solution
and whether it will win in the
marketplace who knows but if you want to
look into this check out a system called
site EB which is something I am involved
in and this thing called site EB R which
is the way you talk are you know in a
side DB context so in my opinion at
least technically this sort of stuff
points the way to the most efficient
long term solution so now let's move to
the future of spark so spark has no
persistence no sharing and move moves
the data to the query so what's almost
guaranteed to happen it's already
happening is the DBMS vendors realize
that they're the companion storage
engine underneath spark and they're
realizing that what you want to do is
push down everything you can into the
database system so push down filters to
push down joins push down everything
where it gets more efficient so the last
thing you want to do is do the sequel up
in the spark layer you want to do it
down in a database layer so DBMS is will
be a persistent layer persistence layer
underneath spark you can just see what's
coming which is tighter and tighter and
tighter integration with spark stuff
just being called inside database
engines so the database guys will
attempt to move spark as simply you know
a computation platform along with our
and anything else and that will that
will give spark a serious case a serious
headache because
you'll have the database vendors
offering superior functionality superior
performance so that might well happen
but in the meantime this is all the Wild
West which is who knows what what's
going to happen what will the spark
market look like in two years will it
just be user defined functions inside of
data warehouse systems will it be user
defined functions inside of array
database systems will spark become a
storage manager to try and get this
tighter integration which is what the
data science guys are I think going to
want so anyway this hold on to your
seatbelt and the interesting thing is
that this is going to be a lot of
disruption no matter what and that means
opportunity for people with good ideas
okay so that's all I have to say about
big volume now let's talk about the
second V which is big velocity well I
I've been involved in two companies in
this space and they they are good at
very different things so again since we
know a little bit about electronic
trading now let's take what the
electronic trading guys want to do which
is they're looking for a pattern in a
firehose as the ticks go by you on CNBC
so find me a strawberry followed within
a hundred milliseconds by a banana so
it's that kind of stuff that they want
to do okay so this is called complex
event processing in most venues and
there's a bunch of systems from a decade
ago like stream base that are pretty
good at this there's a bunch of new
entrants like storm and Kafka that are
pretty good at this and so go buy a CEP
system if you want to look for a pattern
and a firehose so the only problem with
is storm is the slowest thing on the
planet so use something else Kafka is
pretty good
Kafka has a couple problems that we'll
talk about in the next slide
but the second approach and I'll again
illustrate it using a electronic trading
example there's a big electronic trading
company in Chicago called get Co as of a
couple years ago they've single-handedly
accounted for about 12% of the New York
Stock Exchange trading volume they have
an electronic trading desk in New York
in Chicago in Singapore in Tokyo London
dot so they're all over the world and so
they have these independent systems
trading electronically
this isn't millisecond granularity by
the way so the get Co CFO says if we
just let everybody do their own thing
what do I do if everybody Schwartz IBM
at the same time that just will generate
too much risk so what I want to do is
assemble my worldwide position for or
against every stock I'm trading on
millisecond or less granularity so
basically for every a security assemble
my real-time global position so and
alert me if my exposure is greater than
some amount so that's exactly their
application and you you look at this and
you get in a message and the message
says Tokyo bought a hundred shares of
IBM all you want to do is have a
database and update the state of IBM in
that database you want to do this
reliably the minute you lose a message
or lose that update your database is
worthless you need H a because if you
fail then everything is worthless so
this looks like high-performance OLTP so
there are a bunch of systems that are
pretty good at high performance OLTP
they usually go under the rubric new
sequel engines so you want to do a
million sequel transactions a second
volte be will be happy to do that there
are other systems mem sequel that are
pretty good at doing this
so high-performance OLTP says reliably
run transactions with failover and
failback and never lose a message and
make sure you do you process every
message exactly once because you can't
process it twice and you can't process
it zero times okay so in my opinion
there's a market called important stuff
if there's money in your message chances
are you want to think of this as
important if you're tagging ducks and
they're walking around in the marsh you
can lose lots of messages doesn't matter
the important messages are ones that
people are going to pay money for and in
this world you you demand a che and most
people have have pipelines that are
several steps long not just one and and
people want exactly once semantics the
the minute there's money involved it's
got to be exactly one semantics so
transactions with transactional
replication do exactly this and volt DB
and and mem seek will do exactly this
and the other guys like Kafka you have
to work your butt off to figure out how
to do this it can be done but it is a
lot of customization so my prediction is
that in the important message market the
OLTP guys are going to win and the
important message market is anytime
there's money involved which makes this
a high-value market and at the low end
if you're tracking ducks you know
there's no money there anyway so in my
opinion the the OLTP guys are going to
win in this market so what are the storm
clouds to the new sequel guys well first
of all our DMA has appeared on the scene
so and it's pretty darn fast
so that will enable new concurrency
control schemes that the current new
sequel guys don't implement because
they want to try hard to avoid sending
messages that's one possible storm cloud
second one is Google introduced a system
called spanner spanner has synchronous
wide-area replication so get Co wants
two copies of their database because if
one fails you've got to failover to the
other one transactionally and Google
spanner is happy to have the second
database than Chicago the primary
database you know here in Palo Alto so
they're willing to do wide area
synchronous replication the reason they
can do this with with latency that's
tolerable is that they control the
end-to-end network and nobody else does
so you've got spanner works because they
have the end-to-end solution and they
can optimize all stages to keep them
latency modest if you can do spanner
like things then it's certainly possible
that wide area synchronous replication
will become the norm from both the B's
point of view they don't really care
right now you can have synchronous
wide-area replication or asynchronous
wide-area replication take your pick
if and everybody chooses to vote with
their dollars saying I'll take
asynchronous thank you very much because
I can't tolerate the latency people
choose the other way they won't care so
this is all going to be very modest
disruption at best so the CEP guys will
Duke it out with the OLTP guys and I
don't see a lot of serious storm clouds
in this world so where is the 800-pound
gorilla it's in the big variety space so
typical enterprise you ask somebody like
FedEx how many operational databases do
you guys have the answer is about 5,000
you ask for aizen how many operational
databases they have it's about 10,000 so
all of these guys have a data warehouse
and so I asked everyone I can
how many of your operational data
sources get into your data warehouse the
answer is typically less than ten so
what about the other forty 990 they are
silos that don't get shared with anybody
so the other thing that's that's getting
everybody is that there's a lot of data
that's of interest to the corporation
that isn't in anybody's operational data
store so the CFO almost certainly does
his budget on on his local laptop you
know in a spreadsheet that's not in -
that's not shared in any way and there's
a lot of low-end access databases etc
etc so a lot more data sources than
5,000 that you'd like to capture and
then the other thing is everybody wants
to integrate data off the public web so
for example since you guys are now are
all experts on El Nino and La Nina cuz
it it impacts the heck out of your
weather I got to make a sales call at
Miller Beer a few years ago and this was
in December of a year where the weather
guys were saying El Nino is coming El
Nino is coming so we all know that and
we knew at the time that that that makes
it warmer than normal in the Northeast
and wetter than normal in California and
that's exactly what happened this year
so the question I asked the Miller beer
guys was you know is VR beer sales
correlated with weather with
precipitation or temperature Miller beer
guys had a data warehouse sales of beer
by brand by time period by this by that
by the other thing and they all said I
wish we could answer that question but
of course weather data was not in their
data warehouse this is public data that
they could readily integrate off the
public web they just didn't at the time
I have no idea whether they do it now so
there's pressure to get integrate more
and more data sources so the traditional
solution if you go ask anybody who runs
a data warehouse
how do you ingest data into your data
warehouse they will all say they do it
using informatica or using you know an
IBM IBM system called information
integrator how this works is you take
your smartest programmer and you have
them construct a global schema this is
how the data is going to look in the
data warehouse up front I'll come back
in a bit as to why that's hard but
anyway so you construct a global schema
then for every local data source that
you want to integrate you send a
programmer out to interview the business
owner of the day of the data set figure
out what's in it how it's how its
formatted figure out how to do an
extract how to map it to a the global
schema invariably you have to transform
the data because if it's coming from
Europe then the money is in euros and
here it's in dollars and you got to do a
conversion so you got to write a script
to transform the data worse yet you got
to clean it and we'll come back to
cleaning but figure if you want a
reasonable figure of metric merit twenty
percent of your data is wrong and no one
claims it's less than twenty percent is
wrong so and you and if you're gonna put
stuff together if you put together dirty
data that will you will create a mess so
you've got to clean the data and then if
Mike Stonebraker is in one database and
Michael are stone breakers another you
got to entity consolidation so you have
to figure out how to do all this stuff
and this is a labor-intensive
with an expensive programmer so this
works twist my arm I'll give you 25 data
sources really twist it hard and I'll
give you 50 this doesn't work for
hundreds it's just too labor-intensive
so who wants to integrate more than 25
or 50 data sources well here's the few
examples of real-world companies that
really wanted
you this okay so there's a large
manufacturing enterprise which is in
fact General Electric if you want to if
you work for General Electric and you
want to buy a paperclip you've got to
deal with a procurement system so the
procurement system says here's a
purchase order go down to your local
staples and it'll give you your
paperclips
so they have three hundred and twenty
five separate procurement systems you
guys are laughing that's how many they
have why do they have so many well they
have they buy companies on a routine
basis and they have usually come with
their own procurement system so they
have lots of procurement systems CFO had
the bright idea suppose we could put
together these three hundred and twenty
five systems what that would mean is
that if you were a purchase purchase
officer for one of these systems and
your contract with Staples came up for
renewal you could find out what the
other three hundred and twenty four guys
had managed to negotiate because the
terms and conditions and all of these
procurement systems are wildly different
so if you could just get most favored
nation status GE would save a hundred
million dollars a year you know after a
while this actually gets to be a big
number so ge is deadly serious about
integrating three hundred and
twenty-five data sources cuz the upside
if they can solve this problem is huge
who else wants to integrate more than
ten or twenty data sources it turns out
Novartis has about ten thousand bench
scientists chemists and biologists doing
wet stuff in the lab and writing down
their results in think of them as
electronic lab notebooks well with ten
thousand guys some of whom are in
Switzerland some of them are in
Cambridge some of them are elsewhere
scientists in general don't know who
else is working on the same or who
else is producing
the same same output out of different
so they want to integrate 10,000
lab notebooks basically for social
networking purposes again the N is
10,000 and they even admit it's probably
a bigger number by now maybe 15,000
there's a large auto company their
European operation has a customer
database problem in Europe is it has
they have one customer database per
country so when you move from Spain to
France this company and loses you
completely moreover in Germany their
databases are at the Canton level not
even at the country level they have
about a hundred or so databases but
they're in 40 languages and they want to
put them together basically so that for
customer feel good purposes so again n
is way more than 25 so there are lots
and lots of companies who want to do
data integration at scale why do they
have all these data sources the answer
is really pretty straightforward
they enterprises divide themselves into
business units and the business units
are siloed and they're siloed because
you want to be able to get stuff done
without asking everybody up to the
president for permission to do something
or other so virtually every large
enterprise has hundreds to thousands of
these and they have hundreds to
thousands of silos and there's no global
data model there's never a global data
model most every company tried to build
one in the late 1990s and so they take
ten smart people and say go off and
build us you know the Verizon data model
and so these guys would start out doing
if they go interview all these people
and they come back three or four years
later with the state of the world as it
was four years earlier meanwhile the
business has moved on I've never seen a
global data model in any
large enterprise so the figure it
doesn't exist and so it's a bounce to if
there's a global data model then it also
says that which is everybody has got to
use the global data model and standards
are impossibly difficult to enforce just
remember that every enterprise tried to
stamp out max as the desktop device and
that see how well that worked so anyway
there's no global global data model
great ok I'm almost done so everybody
wants to integrate silos for all kinds
of good reasons integration silos is
hard it's hard because you have to do
everything that's up here on the slide
most of which I've already talked about
why is this hard well here are three
possible transactions
I bought a 100k of widgets from IBM
incorporated I bought an 800 K euros of
M widgets from IBM SA which is the
Spanish subsidiary I bought - $9.99 of
Starwood star from this address which
happens to be the headquarters of IBM in
the US so put those three data records
together and it's a little difficult
because you might not know that 800 K is
in Euros - 9 9 9 9 is likely the code
for null and but it's who knows if
that's really the case
Starwood star means what you got dirty
data how to translate currencies because
you know this is you know a
multinational system is IBM sa the same
thing as IBM Incorporated got to do
entity resolution our M wits the edge
it's the same thing as widgets all of
these problems appear and they're all a
challenge so this is hard data
integration that scale is the 800-pound
gorilla in the corner it's the biggest
problem facing a lot of enterprise
is huge upside and impossible to solve
using traditional techniques so it's the
800-pound gorilla in the corner there's
a bunch of startups with interesting
ideas the traditional vendors ETL is not
going to work
it just isn't gonna scale so take a look
at a bunch of a bunch of these companies
there's interesting ideas in my opinion
if you're going to do this at scale
you've got to pick the low hanging fruit
automatically that means machine
learning and statistics there's never a
global schema you've got to build it up
bottom-up and you when you don't know
what to do you've got to be able to ask
a human but the human you ask is not the
ETL programmer it's a business guy
because he's the only one who knows that
star and star with star what it might
mean
so tamer is doing this stuff others are
doing this kind of stuff this this I
think is a huge problem so I have two
more slides this one which is what's
this got to do with data lakes or what
does data lakes got to do with data
integration put all your data into a
data Lake what you've managed to do so
far is ingest all the data into a common
place that is 5% of the problem 1% of
the problem you've still got all of this
other hard stuff to do that will
generate a swamp for sure it will not
generate a lake and at the very best
this is an enterprise junk drawer in
desperate need of curation so the
takeaway is look for disruption if there
isn't disruption the the big boys are
going to continue to be the big boys so
disruption will mean opportunity and
I've gone through in this talk where I
see they're there to be opportunity and
then look for pain pain means that
enterprises with big checkbooks are
willing to take a risk on startups as
opposed to playing it safe
so look for the 800-pound gorilla in
this space or whatever other space
you're interested in that's the end of
my slides I hope I've made some people
mad by now I'm sure we'll have some
questions so how are these our
non-programmers who know the business
side ever going to interface with the
relational database in the programmers
side they're not they're going to answer
questions you send him email saying our
RM wits the same thing as widgets and
they'll answer yes or no on both sides
well what's going to happen is that your
machine learning system is going to say
I think widgets are the same thing as M
widgets with 80% probability so if
you're if you're assembling medical
records you're not going to be willing
to take 80% automatically so you're just
going to be willing to pay and so you
can you can you can decide how accurate
your machine learning has to be before
you involve a human and this becomes a
cost-benefit trade off and tamer lets
you choose that threshold however you
want and some people in the medical
space will choose it at a hundred
percent most people would choose it at
something less a question and I know if
you judge so so you were talking about
sort of the Duke vs. equal then in my
mind they're different things in Hadoop
is an architecture for a parallel
execution and programs sequel is a
program a query language so it's sort of
like saying that sushi is better than my
Ford Mustang what do you mean when when
you're comparing things like spark and
Duke versus sequel or you see
okay great question well all I was
reporting was history which is Google
said mapreduces the answer then they
figured out that what they really wanted
was secretly so then they said oh my god
you know it's a hive market once hive
and pig existed and so that was new news
that sort of rendered everything they
did pretty much obsolete and so yes it's
Apple apples to oranges and the real
answer in 2016 is that you have a sequel
environment to do data management and
you've got some linear algebra
environment and those have to be tightly
integrated and right now nobody is doing
that very well sine or something it
looks like MapReduce to do parallel
execution of queries oh yeah it's just
their quote yes so there's no there's no
huge technical difficulty to writing
code in our or SPARC and sticking it
inside current data warehouses so that
that's not that difficult and expect all
the vendors to do it okay big problem is
going to be conversion because you got
it you've got to do a cast from the
table to an array and that will be
expensive it says array database systems
might have a chance okay Jonathan
abrasion of course is not a big problem
people in struggling this for at least a
couple of decades and maybe longer than
that license every time somebody who
poses some new standard that's going to
take an existing form ascension or that
into one instead of taking and two one
we take n to n plus one just assigning
defeatist I'd rather come to the
conclusion this is just what is it
fundamentally non-solid the problem is
there's some reason to believe and after
all these decades of trying and failing
that there's some new idea that is going
to make
raishin more solvable that has been
passed the fact that the fact that it is
yet more important to enterprises to
solve this problem and if there's a
hundred million dollars on the table
you're willing to spend ten of it to
solve the problem whereas historically
you weren't willing to you weren't
willing to do ten I mean I think I think
the answer is it's becoming more and
more important to solve it and you can
solve it brute force if you have to it's
just expensive so for instance group on
the you know the daily deal guys so they
they want to create an in a worldwide
database of small businesses and they're
doing that integrating ten thousand web
sources and they have six hundred humans
in Indiana who are doing the heavy
lifting so so people are just willing to
pay if there's an ROI on doing it so I
think the answer is this is either a
Palantir consulting market or pieces of
it will get productized augmented by
some consulting but say in the wild
people are really willing to pay I mean
this is a huge pain point these days and
and just getting bigger because the
longer you don't do it the worse the
problem gets around of your friends
thinking about security I wish I had a
good idea on security because I think
that's a huge problem and I don't I
don't know I I don't have a good idea if
I had a good idea I would really I would
I would be all over it I don't have a
good idea now it's a very important
problem that's along those lines how do
you keep those runaway query 80 database
from just exhausting resources oh yeah
the current warehouse guys all do that
right now right setting setting a budget
and you've seen your budget you know
they kill you okay so I mean that's
that's not difficult at all because they
all keep track of resource consumption
okay and the other questions yes awesome
but why this you missed the
possibilities seek will be coming I'm
sorry customer really based management
systems and I heard you say sequel the
same sentence but maybe I didn't but
it's why the sequel makes sense as a
query language for an array DBMS and
simply there's a fundamentally different
model which would probably want a
different kind of language to describe
operations okay so so the psy.d be guys
have a thing called a race equal which
which has project and join and select
from where it looks like sequel unless
you squint and the minute you squint the
semantics are different and anybody in
the business world says that's a good
idea anybody in the science world who
say in our programmer thinks that's
ridiculous and they want a functional
language that says join this to this and
then do that and then do the following
thing so excit b has both interfaces
take your pick how i think what's gonna
have to happen a society v is focused
almost completely on the genomics market
and what those guys actually want for a
query language remains to be seen and so
tidy b will do whatever those guys want
and I think it'll it'll unfold over time
one two three so I'm just wondering what
were your thoughts around growth
databases in query languages as near as
I can tell in the in the complex
analytics world it's 80 or 90 percent
arrays and 10 or 20 percent graphs and
zero percent tables and there are some
people who are really interested in in
graph databases the CIA is my best
example if you think they're keeping a
database of every phone number and who
talk
to who I didn't tell you this but you
assume it's true and they're looking for
terrorist cells which is compute
computer compute clicks in a in a graph
we had a little contract with them that
did this and we did a little benchmark
that had a hundred million phones and
looked for clicks and a hundred million
phones and their reaction was that's not
nearly big enough so so there are
definitely people who really want to do
graph calculations at scale and so I
think it's it's a market it's definitely
a market but I think it's smaller than
the array market hey I mean it's a big
pain point but then to do it once and
then you have some data integrator now
you want to get into another data source
do you think people are offering
incremental approach this method shall
then make it easier cheaper to integrate
that that's the hope that is the hope
because if that's not true then it's a
Palantir style consulting tear exactly
and so the hope is is that there's
enough commonality that you can do a
bunch of this with a product as opposed
to just custom couldn't right now it's
just a hole no I do have pretty well
okay you know you if you focus narrowly
then then you can get then there's a lot
of commonality focusing broadly is not
going to work Carter
what's the future of no sequel databases
well there's a hundred and fifty or 200
commercial products and I think all the
two of them have to go out of business
that's a good question I mean I think I
think the aunt the simple answer is that
the no sequel guys first of all they
need standards because 150 disparate
systems have no chance yeah
so what's the standard going to be well
it's equal because st. Cassandra and
are both building high level
interfaces that unless you squint look
like sequel so no sequel to me means not
yet sequel and I think the other thing
is that is being embarrassed by
not having a good transaction system and
so I think and I think the relational
guys are all implementing JSON to do do
better on semi structured data so I
think no sequel and sequel they're gonna
merge and may the best vendors wind
you